y seguimos con revista de prensa para
hacer un repaso con nuestra periodista
rosa pero es más de eeuu como los medios
internacionales están cubriendo las
noticias rosa buenos días para usted
como esta buenos días media clara pues
un tema del día muy claro estoy relevo
en el poder en reino unido- exactamente
y precisamente vamos a empezar por ahí
cuéntenos cómo repasa la prensa
británica la llegada al poder de listo
así empecemos con the times que dice
directa al grano tras planea congelar
las tarifas energéticas entre temores de
una bancarrota general y de gharyan tras
gana pero puede evitar la acechante
crisis señala que el partido está
dividido que al final listas ganó con un
57% de los apoyos frente al 42 por
ciento de risas una que recordemos el
secretario de finanzas también de boris
johnson y que a pesar de esta división
en el partido listas ex secretaria de
exteriores desafía los llamados a la
unidad y que en su gabinete se espera
que nombre a sus fieles seguidores y
bueno ya vamos a ver si los nombra o no
detrás de ustedes veíamos a the
independent que dice y atrás se enfrenta
a una carrera contrareloj
dice los británicos desesperados piden
ayuda urgente con las facturas de
energía y los tories los miembros del
partido conservador la formación de
listas advierten que tiene meses para
salvar el partido y the daily mirror
vemos en esta foto un poco digamos
psicodélica los últimos cuatro primeros
ministros de todos conservadores david
cameron theresa may boris johnson y lis
atrás y con la siguiente información
durante 12 años primeros ministros del
partido conservador han hundido la
economía maltratado nuestros servicios
públicos han empeorado la situación para
muchas personas y de nuevo tenemos al
mismo viejo conservador se me otorga y
lo llaman pero bastante dura esta
posición ahora hagamos un repaso por las
portadas internacionales cómo está
registrando esta noticia financial times
dice tras preparada para el poder en
reino unido- y le monten francia señala
una ultra liberal en downing street o
una ultra liberal que declaró en
términos económicos
con los principales medios de nuestra
región empezando en brasil con el
'veolia' de sao paulo dice la
conservadora lista es la nueva primera
ministra británica y el clarín de
argentina destaca una cita de atrás
respecto a las malvinas no dice las
malvinas son parte de la familia
británica bueno ya veíamos entonces
también el clarín que es el medio
argentino como usted lo dijo y ahora hay
un común denominador para listados y es
que muchos la consideran como la
sucesora de margaret thatcher la dama de
hierro exactamente ella así se lo
señalan muchísimas portadas alrededor
del mundo hemos seleccionado nada
solamente cuatro empezando por el mundo
de españa que dice liz tras tras la
estela de margaret thatcher y que su
elección confirma un volantazo hacia la
derecha más dura luego la estampa de
italia soñando con thatcher la república
también de italia dice la nueva dama de
hierro que debe salvar gran bretaña y
lakua de francia la nueva dama de hierro
dice la muy radical lis atrás asume el
cargo de boris johnson bueno y en
skynews cuéntenos qué piensan los
políticos
skynews hace un repaso como decía del
círculo cercano de lis atrás y las
declaraciones que han hecho al respecto
de la que ya es primera ministra del
reino unido- restricción al recordemos
su rival conservador dijo que el partido
finalmente el todo el partido tory el
partido conservador es una familia y
debe apoyarla boris johnson dijo sé que
tiene el plan correcto para resolver la
crisis económica palabras de unidad
parecidas pronunciaron theresa may david
cameron y que es también líder líder del
partido laborista dijo que no está del
lado de la gente trabajadora y en
skynews encontrábamos que hay un
programa de la televisión británica itv
y llamado this morning que están
diciendo detrás pues ahora vamos a
entrar en esto mar y aclara si te parece
pero antes no queríamos terminar esta
sección sin hacer un repaso un poco de
las perspectivas que le auguran a list
tras tanto the gardian como el mont que
dicen que vive básicamente desconectada
de la realidad de los británicos the
gardian en su editorial le reprocha que
no tiene capacidad de diagnosis de los
problemas del reino unido- y que si
sigue
vacaciones de la realidad no durará
mucho en el cargo lo mismo le augura el
mont que dice que su discurso el liberal
parece desconectado de la depresión
económica y social que atraviesa el
reino unido- y respecto a la guerra en
ucrania en kiev independent dice que
espera que liz atrás esté tan
comprometida con ucrania como lo estuvo
boris johnson mientras que por parte de
rusia tenemos el consoló macaya pravda
una medio con una línea muy dura que
dice que atrás está obsesionada con el
odio a los rusos como demostró siendo
ministra de exteriores así que esperan
que londres mantenga la misma línea
hostil hacia moscú ahora que dicen
francamente ya estamos acostumbrados y
en relación con la guerra de ucrania y
cómo afecta a la situación energética en
el reino unido- y en toda europa hemos
como decía seleccionado un fragmento de
un programa de televisión que ayer se
hizo viral y que parece una parodia pero
refleja muy bien la situación energética
en reino unido escuchemos
allá vamos aquí tenemos te pagan dos mil
libras la factura eléctrica creo que
durante cuatro meses si se detiene aquí
así que como son sus facturas eléctricas
está un poco preocupado al respecto no
muchísimo tengo uno de estos contadores
de prepago y es letal
bueno esperemos que se tengan una de
estas casillas sea como sea va a ganar
dinero así que no se preocupe allá vamos
sada nieve acá allá vamos gira y gira
nadie sabe dónde va a parar
da da da da mil libras o factura
eléctrica mil libras o factura eléctrica
es que es que se tape
es tu factura eléctrica oh dios mío
muchas gracias le vamos a pagar su
factura eléctrica durante cuatro meses
fantástico no te preocupes wow qué
alivio muchas gracias
increíble a lo que han llegado los
británicos rosa gracias y nosotros
seguimos con nuestro primer invitado
elige